Kids, hello and welcome to Introduction
to High Performance Computing or
Intro the HPC for short.
My name is Rich Vuduc, and
I'm a professor here in the School of
Computational Science and
Engineering at Georgia Tech.
I'll be your guide in this course as
you explore what I think are some of
the big ideas in how to
extract parallelism and
data locality from algorithms and
data structures.
I thought we'd kick things off here at
the Klaus Advanced Computing Building.
It's one of the main places on the GT
Campus where HPC is proudly spoken.
Oh, Viva la HPC.
Now there's another
reason to start here to.
Although you might be attending
the course from some remote
part of the globe, I wanted to remind
you while your in my course at least,
you're still here with us in spirit.
And that makes you part of
the Georgia Tech family.
So with that,
let's head to my office in Klaus, and
I'll tell you a little bit
more about the course.